Since our mind-blowingly popular first lesson
featuring Eminem we've received thousands of
messages from you guys asking for another one!
So today we're bringing you a lesson with his
hit song Rap God! Now this six minute song
features a bunch of different references to
different comic books to his old songs and
one of the great things for you to practice
your English is that he raps insanely fast and
will help you to understand everything. Just a
warning if you are a bit sensitive this has some
profane language in it especially the F word
so you might want to watch one of our more family
friendly lessons, but if not let's jump in to the
first part of the
song.
Hey if you're new here every single week we
make learning English fun just like this!
So that you can understand fast speaking natives,
without getting lost without missing the jokes
and without subtitles. Just like our fan Sitar who
says that our lessons are the only way of learning
English he's found that actually works. So we'll
help you to really improve your english fluency
and comprehension. It's simple join over 3 million
learners from around the world by hitting that
subscribe button and the bell below and you
won't miss a single one of our new lessons!
Hey I bet if you're watching this then
you would like to be able to understand
natives even when we speak really fast or rap
really fast. Well we will help you to do it
and a really great place to start is with our
three-part Masterclass. Now in this Masterclass
we'll teach you the three keys to being able to
understand natives at any speed and those are
vocabulary, pronunciation and cultural context.
The best part is you can sign up absolutely free
so to learn more and join all you have to do
is click up here or down description below!
In this video you're going to learn English
with one of the best and most popular rappers
of all time Eminem! We're covering portions
of three of his hit songs in this lesson.
Lose yourself, the real Slim Shady
and the Monster featuring Rihanna.